get ready to learn English with Harry
Potter and the order of the Phoenix is
important but there's something that
matters even though believing in
yourself think of it this way every
great wizard in history started out as
nothing more than what we are now
students if they can do it why not us
really quick before we get into the
lesson I want to let you know that if
you're new here every single week we
make fun lessons like this one so that
you can understand fast speaking natives
without getting lost without us in the
jokes and without subtitles just like
Hassan who says that our videos are like
magic for his English fluency and your
comprehension and confidence are going
to increase a lot too just with that
subscribe button and the belt down below
so you don't miss any of our new lessons
[Music]
this is the mat you're going to be
taught by me I'm an otter remember look
on the bright side I can't be any worse
than old toad face thanks from a feeling
who's supposed to be meeting it's done
lovely spot thought it'd be safer some
off the beaten track hi so you will know
why we're here need a teacher proper
teacher one who's had real experience
defending themselves against the dark
arts why why because you know who's back
you
tosspot so he says so Dumbledore says so
Dumbledore says because he says the
point is where's the proof
Potter could tell us more about her
dickory got killed I'm not gonna talk
about Cedric so if that's why you're
here you might as well clear out now
let's go there just say exacta Khan some
sort of freak it's a true you can
purchase Petronas China
yes I've seen it
well I'm a hurry I didn't know you could
do that you kill the basilisk with the
sword in Dumbledore's office it's true
third year he fought about hundred
Dementors at once last year he really
did fight off you-know-who in the flash
wait look it all sounds great when you
say it like that but the truth is most
of that was just luck I didn't know what
I was doing half the time I nearly
always had help he's just being modest
and a miny
I'm not facing this stuff in real life
is not like school in school if you make
a mistake you can just try again
tomorrow but out there when you're a
second away from being murdered or
watching a friend die right before your
eyes you don't know what that's like
you're right Hera we don't that's why we
need your help because if we're going to
have any chance of beating Voldemort
it's really back
[Music]
this is math you're gonna be taught by
me I mean not to remember if somebody
says that something is mad or madness
they mean that it's too dangerous or
stupid to be done this application is
more commonly seen in British English
since in American English natives will
usually say that something is crazy
check out these two examples all the
mortars chosen Draco Malfoy for a
mission I know it sounds much as it
occurred to Harry that Snape was simply
pretending to offer Draco help so he
could find out what he was up to
also in informal American English the
adjective mad when co-located with a
person is more often associated with
being angry let's see another example is
everything alright
oh oh oh hey listen don't be mad at him
it's our fault I'm sorry we've been
hogging so much of his time
so then Harry reminds Hermione that no
one would want to learn with him
this is Matt you're gonna be taught by
me I mean not to remember he says
everyone thinks he is a nutter
similarly to mad only more informal the
now nutter is a british slang expression
for calling a person crazy or strange
another man that was arrested for the
shooting how does a nutter like that get
through your security
what's a similar expression to nutter
used in american english for describing
a crazy or strange person
[Music]
yes this is not how we wanted you to
find out about this you have every right
to go nuts
I'm not going nuts do you see me going
nuts no but you know what hey hey hey
you're gonna be taught by me I mean not
to remember look on the bright side I
can't be any worse than old totally the
expression the bright side refers to the
advantages or good things in a bad
situation example John is sick and can't
go to work on the bright side he'll
finally have some extra time to spend
with his family so if somebody says look
on the bright side they are going to
point out a positive aspect of something
bad you can't believe it's raining again
someone fare well on the bright side now
we won't have to see all these
paleontologists with their shirts off
not you guys you've got it going on
which of these expressions has a similar
meaning to the bright side so we might
say the silver lining to refer that in
every negative event we can find
something positive if we try example you
lost his job but the silver lining is
that one week later he got offered an
even better one so Ron goes on to say
that the bright side is that Harry
cannot be any worse than old toad face
that is Professor Umbridge so he should
be feeling good about that a toad is an
animal similar to a frog Ron thinks
Umbridge has a face like this animal
look on the bright side
can't be any worse than Oh totally
thanks from mate is an informal friendly
way of addressing someone especially a
man it's commonly used in British and
Australian English maybe you don't have
to do this all by yourself like in the
United States you may hear other
expressions such as dude or man do you
have a minute dude what am I got
Rachel's here so good luck man let me
know how it works out what's funny about
this exchange is that you can imply Ron
meant Harry is a terrible teacher but
that he cannot be any worse than umbrage
so Harry sarcastically thanks Ron and
here's bonds I'm here for you which is
something you would actually say to a
friend to show them support thanks Ron
everything we're supposed to be making
is done did you notice how Hermione
pronounced this expression in spoken
English we often make use of connected
speech that is we cut reduce and link
the sounds of different words so first
of all you'll notice Hermione connects
the words couple and of when this
happens the phrase a couple of becomes
the sound a couple of now if you listen
closely you'll hear she actually reduces
the word of to a simple sound which is
something natives often do so by doing
that she reduces it even more to a
coupla alright mom we'll have a cup of
tea I want to show you something
let's practice repeating after her
ten inches nothing special I record I'll
do
to go for a couple of weeks ago I
appreciate the thought but really given
the fact that we were almost killed by
couple of Death Eaters few minutes ago
another interesting thing you should
know about this phrase if this sometimes
Natives drop the word of all together
both in writing and speaking
so in Hermione sentence she could have
said either a couple of people or just a
couple people check out these other
examples finding that paper of yes I'm
not the guy who cut a school and I so
get to me really I actually almost
bought it hook line and sinker I was out
of town for a couple months is what you
call accountability hey I just wanted to
let you know that the most fun way to
increase your comprehension natives and
confidence communicating is with our
fluent with friends course in this forty
eight week course you will learn
alongside the first two seasons of the
TV series friends with 20-plus page PDF
power lessons vocabulary memorization
software access to our fluency circle
global community and so much more and
the best part is you can try for free
right now with our three-part master
class all you have to do is click up
here or down scription below it to learn
more and sign up and I look forward to
meeting you inside lovely spot lovely is
an adjective use for describing anything
as Pleasant enjoyable or beautiful it's
also a common adjective of choice for
sarcastic remarks like iran's about the
spot hermione chose for the meeting by
the way you'll hear lovely used more in
british english than american english
thought it is say for some
off-the-beaten-track if a place is off
the beaten track it is not visited or
used by a lot of people this expression
is also used to refer to anything that
is done differently from the usual way
so Hermione here means she believes the
hogshead pub is a safe option as a
location for their secret meeting
considering how unpopular it is example
when you're in Denver you have to go to
this little Mexican restaurant I know
it's a little off the beaten track but
they make the best tacos you've ever had
[Music]
hi so you will know why we're here need
a teacher proper teacher proper is an
address of common in British English for
something or somebody that is
appropriate or suitable to a situation
or that is considered legitimate actual
real now stop it in the movie Dolores
Umbridge is the current Defense Against
the Dark Arts teacher at Hogwarts and
she refuses to teacher stewards any
effective practical ways of defending
themselves so Hermione here says that
they need a teacher but considering
umbrage is their teacher she then adds
they need a proper teacher you need a
teacher proper teacher
one who's had real experience defending
themselves against the dark arts did you
know the pronoun they and it's
derivative forms them they're theirs in
themselves can be used to refer to a
single person well there are many
possible applications for the singular
they it's most commonly used when the
gender of the person referred to is
unknown to the speaker example somebody
left their umbrella in the office could
you please let them know where they can
get it proper teacher one who's had real
experience defending themselves against
the dark arts why why because you know
whose back you tosspot you know who is
an expression used to refer to someone
without having to say their name in the
Wizarding World
the wizard Voldemort is also known as
you-know-who since everyone would fear
uttering his real name especially in
public spaces where other people could
be hearing tosspot is a British English
slang expression used for insulting
other people similar to idiot or stupid
because you know who's back you
toshko so he says sir Dumbledore says so
Dumbledore says because he says the
point is where's the proof when we talk
about the point of something we're
referring to the most important fact or
idea behind something in the scene
Zakaria Smith is saying the point of his
position against their idea is that
there is no proof that Baltimore is back
Potter could tell us more about how
eager he got killed I'm not going to
talk about Cedric so if that's why
you're here you might as well clear out
now if you tell someone to clear out or
clear off of a place you are telling
them rather rudely to leave the place
I'm not gonna talk about Centrex if
that's why you're here you might as well
clear out now freak is a word used to
describe a thing person animal or event
that is extremely unusual or unlikely
different from any other of its type
example a freak snowstorm hit New York
in the middle of this spring be careful
when collocating this with people as an
infers they are extremely strange or
creepy I was the only one to see her for
watch it's a true you can produce a
Patronus child yes
I've seen it well I'm a hurry I didn't
know you could do that you say blimey
when you're surprised by something or
feel strongly about it like the
expression damn oh damn I got it on my
pants here I'll get it
why me that's one big one
it's true third year you fought about
hundred Dementors of ones if you are
fighting off someone you are defending
yourself against someone by fighting
last year he really did fight off
you-know-who in the flashlight if you
meet or see someone in the flesh you
actually meet or see them rather than
for example seeing them in a film or on
television in the case of Hermione's
sentence she met that Harry fought off
Voldemort himself in person not just his
followers for example it all sounds
great when you say it like that but the
truth is most of that was just luck I
didn't know what I was doing half the
time I nearly always had help he's just
being modest Hermione or not
if a person is modest he or she is
successful but does not call attention
to this fact they do not want to talk
about their abilities or achievements
facing this stuff in real life is not
like Scholl if you face a problem or a
situation you have to solve or deal with
it concentrate right
[Music]
Dumbledore warned butter this could
happen it's gonna get us all killed cuz
he comedies the truth when talking about
people to face somebody can also mean to
go against them or fight them in school
if you make a mistake you can just try
again tomorrow
but out there when you're a second away
from being murdered or watching a friend
die right before your eyes out there
refers to anywhere except here where the
speaker is at so Harry is talking about
how difficult it was to watch a friend
die right before his eyes in the
expression right before somebody's eyes
the word before means in front of so if
something happens right before your eyes
it happens right in front of you hey
Margo have you checked out
all of our lessons with Harry Potter yet
if not then you're definitely watch I
got this playlist after you finished in
this video by clicking up here or down
in the description below
[Music]
this is mad you're gonna be taught by me
I'm an otter remember look on the bright
side I can't be any worse than old toad
face thanks from me if you think who's
supposed to be meeting is done lovely
spot thought it'd be safer some off the
beaten track
um hi so you all know why we're here
need a teacher proper teacher one who's
had real experience defending themselves
against the dark arts why why cuz you
know who's back you
tosspot so he says so Dumbledore says so
Dumbledore says because he says the
point is where's the proof
Potter could tell us more about her
dickory got killed I'm not gonna talk
about Cedric so if that's why you're
here you might as well clear out now
exactly cause I'm sort of freak it's a
true you can't produce a Patronus child
yes I've seen it
why me Harry I didn't know you could do
that you killed a basilisk with the sod
in Dumbledore's office it's true third
year he fought about hundred Dementors
at once last year he really did fight
off you-know-who in the flash wait
[Music]
look it all sounds great when you say it
like that but the truth is most of that
was just luck I didn't all I was doing
half the time I nearly always had help
he's just being modest my knee I'm not
facing this stuff in real life is not
like a skull in school if you make a
mistake you can just try again tomorrow
but out there when you're a second away
from being murdered or watching a friend
die right before your eyes you don't
know what that's like
you're right Harry we don't that's why
we need your help
because if we're going to have any
chance of beating Voldemort
it's really back
[Music]
all right I hope you had an awesome time
learning English today with Harry Potter
and remember if you want to add a touch
of magic to your learning then you'll
definitely not want to miss all of our
lessons teaching you English with Harry
Potter over here and now it's time to go
beyond the classroom and live your
English hi-yah